during the autumn of 2010
the federal reserve embarked on what at
the time was the latest
in a series of extraordinary policy
initiatives
that were designed to ease the downward
force
of the great recession on unemployment
and output
on november 3rd 2010 the federal
open market committee the fed committee
charged with the responsibility to make
monetary policy decisions
announced that it would purchase
an additional 600 billion dollars
of longer maturity government securities
over the coming months that policy
came to be called quantitative easing
two
the fomc explained that the purpose of
this measure was
quote to promote a stronger pace of
economic recovery end quote
and restated its view that the policy
was
consistent with its commitment to
maintain
inflation at mandated levels
but not all members of the fomc voted
for this policy initiative thomas
hayning
voted no because he was concerned that
and i quote this continued
high level of monetary accommodation
increased the risks of future financial
imbalances
and over time would cause an increase
in long-term inflation expectations
that could destabilize the economy
end quote
during the period beginning with the
failure of lehman brothers in 2008
the federal reserve and the federal open
market committee
entered uncharted waters
by expanding the kinds of policy
initiatives that they
undertook and the degree of commitment
they made to soften the blow of the
great recession and its evil twin
the subprime mortgage financial market
crisis
the new federal reserve initiatives have
led some to criticize ben bernanke
the chair of the federal reserve board
of governors
some of bernanke's critics are worried
and were worried
that the unprecedented attempts by the
fed
to expand credit would ultimately lead
to increased inflation rates in the
united states
at a meeting where he appeared on a
panel with alan greenspan
bernanke said and i quote we're not in
the business of trying to create
inflation
our purpose is to provide some
additional stimulus
to help the economy recover and to avoid
potentially additional disinflation
end quote but even some
fed insiders were unconvinced
e gerald corrigan a former president of
the federal reserve bank of new york
said that he felt quote uneasiness
end quote about the latest fed decision
in this lecture i seek to answer two
questions
first what is normal federal reserve
policy
while i discussed how the fed changes
the federal funds rate
in the previous lecture in this lecture
i will return to that question in a new
way
that quantifies what normal means and
explains
why it was reasonable for the fed to
believe
that normal policy would not
provide a sufficient remedy to the
financial market crisis in the great
recession
the second question i'd like to address
is what exactly
did the fed do during these crisis years
and why did ben bernanke and members of
the fomc
believe that these steps would aid the
economy
here again we are going to have to look
to behavior
by the banking sector to understand the
fre
the federal reserve's thinking
in a later lecture i will explain what
other central banks were doing
to stimulate their economies during the
financial market crisis in the great
recession
in particular i'll ask whether
it appeared that central banks were
somehow
coordinating their policy or
if they each went with their each went
their own way but for now
i'm going to focus on the extraordinary
behavior
and the extraordinary policy initiatives
that were unt
undertaken by the federal reserve after
2008.
so let's begin by looking at normal
federal reserve policy in a new way that
helps us
understand why normal policy
was inadequate to deal with the
financial market crisis
and the great recession
we can both understand and quantify
the concept of normal federal reserve
policy using that taylor rule that we
learned about in the last lecture
recall that the taylor rule specifies
that the federal funds rate should be
adjusted
in accordance with a rule or
an equation the variables in the formula
are the federal funds rate symbolized by
ffr at time t the inflation rate
symbolized by pi t the
target for inflation symbolized by pi
star the output gap
and remember the output gap is positive
when the economy is operating
above its long-run full employment
levels but
negative when the economy is operating
below its long run levels high rates
of unemployment imply negative values
for the output gap
low very low levels of unemployment
imply
positive values for the output gap and
finally
the equation contains the term r star
plus pi star and we came to understand
that
r star plus pi star was the fed's
estimate of the long run equilibrium
value of the federal funds rate
so if the fed were hitting its inflation
target
and the output gap was zero these are
ideal conditions
the fed would be keeping the federal
funds rate
at station keeping r star
plus pi star okay
according to the taylor rule then the
federal reserve should
anchor their federal funds rate at the
nominal rate
of interest implied by the long-run
equilibrium rate
of interest our star and the inflation
rate pi star
and this means that the taylor rule
requires the fed
to set the long-run value for the
federal funds rate
at a level consistent with long-run
equilibrium market forces
not fight against those forces but
cooperate and coordinate with those
forces
now the graph that you're seeing shows
the actual federal funds rate and the
federal funds rate recommended by the
taylor rule
not just during the greenspan years but
between 1987
and 2011 greenspan
and bernanke regime
what do you see in this graph
well you see the actual federal funds
rate
in blue and you see the taylor
rule prescription in green
and you note that the taylor rule
prescription
tracks the actual federal funds rate
pretty well
for the early part of the period
suggesting that the taylor rule provides
a good approximation
of what the fed actually does
note particularly that the federal funds
rate
falls when the taylor rule says it
should fall
and the federal funds rate rises when
the taylor rule
said it should have risen
but note what happens to the taylor rule
prescription in 2008
at that time the output gap became a
large
negative number as real gross domestic
product
fell as much as eight percent below
potential moreover the inflation rate
fell below the target value which
we're using to be we're defining to be
1.5 percent
with those two inputs to the taylor rule
the taylor rule prescribed a
negative value for the federal funds
rate you can see that in the graph
this bears emphasis normal policy
at the time would have been impossible
because normal policy would have
required
a negative value for the federal funds
rate
now during 2008 the fed lowered the
federal funds rate to very near
zero but the taylor rule
which specifies how the federal funds
rate should normally respond to economic
conditions
prescribed even more stimulus a negative
value
and of course a negative federal funds
rate's impossible
this prescription is an indication
of how bad the economy was performing
so the federal reserve responded to
these extraordinarily bad times which
called for
a negative federal funds rate with
extraordinary policy emission
initiatives
what extraordinary measures did the fed
undertake during the great recession
very nicely very usefully the federal
reserve
bank of san francisco provides a cogent
summary of federal reserve initiatives
taken by the fed during the financial
market crisis in the great
recession years and it provides them in
chronological order which helps one get
a nice picture of what was going on
and i think it's helpful to
to say that the federal reserve was
really responding to
three different kinds of problems okay
three different kinds of problems
first the fed provided remedies to
problems
that resulted from the financial crisis
itself well you'll say all the problems
resulted but these were
more direct problems that resulted from
the crisis
during the financial crisis short-term
credit markets ceased functioning
because lenders believed that if the
financial system
failed no creditors would be able to
replay that
repay their debt obligations
evidence of how serious the matter was
can be found by looking at data for the
ted spread
defined to be the difference between the
three-month
london inter-bank lending rate and the
three-month u.s treasury bill rate
okay ted well the t in ted comes from
treasury bill
and the e.d in ted comes from euro
dollar
because the london interbank rate is a
rate on
euro dollar balances
normally the ted spread is very very
small
why loans in london
and treasury bills are very close
substitutes
so people who want the highest possible
interest will buy
uh will hold either treasury bills or
euro dollar balances and they'll
arbitrage
those two rates into very close
agreements so that their
difference is very near zero
but as this as the chart you're looking
at now
shows in 2008
the ted spread spiked
went to very high levels
what did the fed do well the fed
normally provides loans only to
depository institutions
such as banks and normally does through
us
does so through its so-called discount
window
but in march 2008
the fed created two new programs
to provide short-term secured loans
to securities dealers similar
to discount window loans so they
provided loans to
securities dealers the way they would
normally have provided those loans
to banks the graph that you're looking
at now
shows the volume of those loans made
under these two programs short-term
credit markets
improved dramatically in 2009
and the ted spread returned to normal
a sort of victory for the federal
reserve
in the fall of 2008 the fed also
intervened
to improve credit conditions in two
markets that were breaking down
money market mutual funds collect funds
from savers
who consider them safe pool them and use
them to make short-term loans to
businesses
very short-term loans that's one market
second market the commercial paper
market is a
source of short-term loans that
businesses rely on
but after the lehman brothers bankruptcy
savers
feared that commercial paper could
become worthless
and cease lending and started
withdrawing funds
additionally from money market mutual
funds because they
were afraid that they too would use
value
so what did the fed do something
extraordinary again
as a remedy the fed provided secured
loans
to institutions offering commercial
paper and money market mutual funds
so if you were offering if you were
discounting commercial paper for
businesses
or if you were running a money market
mutual fund the
fed was lending to you directly
and as a result those two markets
returned to normalcy
early in 2009
finally in terms of direct effects or or
addressing direct problems of the crisis
the fed intervened to save financial
institutions when it deemed that
failure to those institutions would
undermine the functioning of the
financial system
we've heard already but it's bears
repeating that the fed provided loans to
jp
morgan to assisted in acquiring bear
stearns
and the fed provided loans to aig
because it determined
that that insurance company was not too
big to fail but it was somehow too
connected
to fail recall that aig
had written insurance contracts
on mortgaged back securities
okay before we go forward
remember that while the
fed took some extraordinary measures
we have evidence that those
measures had desirable effects
the ted spread spiked in 2008
and after the fed initiatives those two
markets the one in london
and the one for treasury bills returned
to their normal
functioning
what's the second kind of thing that the
fed did well
the second kind of policy initiative
initiative that we would call
extraordinary
was that the fed provided extraordinary
remedies to problems faced by banks
when banks became reluctant to loan
funds to one another
and the ted spread as evidence of that
the fed increased the availability of
loans from itself to banks
keep in mind that the increase in the
ted spread indicated
that short-term loans from private
institutions were
very hard to get during this period
in particular the fed created the
term auction facility which increased
the availability of one and three-month
discount loans to banks fed's gonna loan
to banks through the discount loan
facility
the fed also increased the availability
of dollar-denominated loans to banks in
other countries
knowing that there was a high demand for
dollars not only
not only in the united states but
elsewhere
the federal deposit insurance
corporation
in coordination with the fed created a
temporary liquidity guarantee program
that provided guarantees on newly issued
bank debt
and expanded coverage of deposit sure
insurance
now clearly this was designed to calm
the nerves
of all participants in financial markets
the fed conducted stress tests of major
banks
why well it wanted to ensure
not only themselves but the public that
the banks could weather future bad
economic times
the purposes of the tests were not only
to force stress banks to raise new
capital
but also to restore confidence in the
stability of the banking system
and not surprisingly the feds supported
systemically important banks by
providing loans to
citigroup and bank of america two banks
that were deemed too big to fail
as a result bank share prices
which had fallen dramatically over 2007
and 2008
stabilized at the beginning of 2009.
one final thing the fed did one final
thing the fed did
the fed beginning in 2008
also began to pay
interest on reserves
that banks deposited with them
providing those banks with another
source of income
that helped to stabilize their bottom
line
the third kind of thing that the federal
reserve did
that we would consider extraordinary was
that the fed
undertook extraordinary initiatives
to stimulate the economy
now as we've already seen the fed
lowered the federal funds rate to
unprecedented levels in late 2008 near
zero
can't get much lower than that
the fed which normally buys and sells
only short maturity treasury security
treasury bills normally in normal times
the fed
only enters the t-bill market
but in these extraordinary times the fed
provided
extra stimulus to the economy by buying
longer term treasury securities and
mortgage-backed securities
it purchased 300 billion of longer
mature
maturity treasuries in 2009 it had
already purchased
one and a quarter trillion dollars of
mortgage-backed securities in 2008.
it guaranteed 175 billion
of fannie mae and freddie mac
outstanding debt
and in the fall of 2010
the fed committed to purchasing an
additional
600 billion of government securities of
longer maturities
this last decision triggered
the doubt that we mentioned at the
outset of the lecture
the fed also supported securitization
of consumer and business loans
now securitization refers to the
practice of creating
derivatives and remember they aren't
necessarily
bad things creating derivatives that
allow
the marketing of bundles of securities
such as mortgages
so loan securitization creates an
important source of funds through which
not only mortgages
but student loans and other credit is
made
more affordable
not surprisingly during the subprime
crisis
securitization dried up but this
threatened dramatic increases in the
cost of mortgages
student loans and similar kind of debt
what did the fed do the fed
created the term asset backed
securities loan facility that provided
credit to those institutions
that engage in securitization those
specialists
the business of whom is to secure
securitized debt
as a result issuance of asset-backed
securities
returned to normal levels in 2009
were these extraordinary policy measures
necessary
well we've already seen that at least
one member of the fomc
and many other doubters believe
that the fed provided too much stimulus
during the great recession and thereby
sowed the seeds of future inflation
but one very powerful way to appreciate
why the fed took the measures it did
is to look at bank balance sheets during
the great recession
the table you are looking at now
clearly shows that the great recession
was a time when banks greatly increased
their holding of excess
reserves
how do i show that well and how does the
table show that
you have two columns in the table the
first
is dated october 2007.
it shows the total reserves of the
banking system
in october 2007 were 42.5 billion
dollars
of those required reserves
were 41 billion dollars and
extra or excess reserves were 1.4
billion dollars
what's that mean the banks
as a group were holding
just a little bit more
of reserves than was required by law
given the deposits they had accepted
from customers
okay these numbers would be
interesting but not really important
except
that they provide a baseline
to think about reserve positions in
october 2009
only two years later
in october 2009 total reserves of the
banking system
were 1 trillion 56 billion
that is not a typographical error 1
trillion
56 billion dollars
of those reserves 61.7 billion were
required
and 994
point billion dollars were excess
reserves reserves that the law did not
require the banks to hold
this more than
any other data i could show you indicate
that commercial banks
were behaving in non-normal
ways in normal times
banks would have responded to those
increases
in reserves with increased lending
and that increased lending would have
raised required reserves because that
increased lending would have created new
deposits for loan customers
but during the great recessions
banks preferred to hold huge quantities
of reserves
rather than to assume the risks of
lending
the bottom line is that
during the financial crisis and the
great recession the fed's
normal policy response lowering the
federal funds rate
was simply inadequate
the taylor rule tells us that times were
so bad that a negative federal funds
rate
an impossibility would have been
warranted
the fed acted boldly to provide credit
and to stabilize the payment system it
acted
because banks would not act
whether it went too far has yet to be
determined
the question that we will answer
sometime in the future
will be whether the fed can reverse
course quickly enough once the economy
begins to grow
robustly if it does
the fed i hope will be credited with the
successful
piloting of the economy through its most
dangerous period since the federal
reserve
was brought by law into existence in
1913
and developed in 1914
but if it does not and
if inflation again rears its ugly head
the fed will be blamed for once
again allowing inflation to be woven
into the fabric of american prices
thank you
[Music]
you